X's Bruce Willis and Demi Moore have
been sharing their quarantine family
album on Instagram but fans have been
wondering where's Bruce's current wife
Emma Heming et has learned that Bruce
pretty much got stuck in Idaho after it
became a cope in 19 hotspot he has a
home across the street from Demi's in
Sun Valley a source tells ET that Emma
and Bruce are very much still together
and that Emma prefers sunny Los Angeles
and she's fine with Bruce being with his
ex and older children another source
says Bruce and Demi have been close
friends for years
they love to spend time as a family with
their children and decided to social
distance together drink emma has even
been leaving supportive comments like
this one on Demi's page saying love and
miss you guys it's everything the
Willises have been keeping busy at one
point Bruce even shaved his daughter
Tallulah's head you look like Joan of
Arc did her sister rumor got in on the
head shaving fun and when they're not
doing at home haircuts
they've also enjoyed having a family
book club and making music together
[Applause]
deme even teased a family photo project
they were working on in quarantine the
girls have been posting plenty of
adorable throwback shots from their
youth this one has such a I don't know a
loveliness to it that I really wanted to
kind of do a throwback to all of them
[Music]